there is an elementary school in shure
that offers some sort of sanctuary
a place of refuge for people on the run
but they have arrived in a city now
gripped by a humanitarian emergency
and there is little here to keep them
alive
there is no food and there is no shelter
and there is no
the basic needs so if you can
you have to address the world to come
soon
a human tide of 300 000 are now camping
in this beleaguered city
after a hazardous journey from western
tigray
and many here both young and old are
struggling
how are you tell me how you're feeling
some have been forced to flee their
homes
others have been banished by militias
from the neighboring region of
amhara the u.s government has called it
ethnic cleansing lady tawel de brahan
and her daughter have just arrived in
shuri
this must be a really difficult time for
you
she's a civil servant from a city called
humera
and she says she's lost everything she
owns
do you know where you are going to sleep
tonight
there's not much space at sahaya
elementary
and conditions at five other camps in
the city are the same
the air filled with smoke and the
continuous sound
of people coughing it's so
claustrophobic in here there's
barely any room to move inside and new
camp residents
are arriving all the time although i
don't think you can call this a
displacement
camp it's more like a test of human
endurance
how are you feeling
on earth
no food no services at this elementary
school
twenty-eight-year-old fitzsim
teclahimanot suffers from a mental
illness
and his father a priest has decided to
keep him
in chains it's the only way they can
cope
with
until recently and the local hospital
can't meet demand
this is the corridor of the main
reception
they are short of beds and routine
medication
like basic pain relief this man was
stitched up without an anesthetic during
our visit
they know the 30 among the 5th the war
in tigre
has put everyone under terrible pressure
says the director
as the physicians we are we we are doing
our best
but it's really harsh the environment is
harsh the time is harsh
and still our stars are also still they
have this psychological trauma including
me psychological trauma because one of
our best pharmacy staff was
killed with his family by the
birthrattles
gunshot wounds and shrapnel injuries
have become a matter of routine
but some patients can't just be patched
up
eight-year-old al abraham was shot in
the head
by militiamen in western tigray
his mother grandmother and brother were
killed
i don't have an idea because he's too
young he's eight years old
later on him his little brother is five
years old
killed by them even they thought that
this was already dead
but later on as you can see there is two
sides of the injury you can see
one was it's a bullet injury and it was
in and
by that side it was also the ability to
get out with us
they've been caught in the middle of a
battle for power
and the war in tigre will never leave
them
john sparks sky news in shuri